[Music]
in the United Kingdom
you may ducks chickens geese and na not
these they all belong to the Queen well
all swans in the United Kingdom can
belong to the Queen but she mainly
exercises this right on the river thames
of course sorry
[Music]
my name's David barber and I look after
the swans wherever the Queen exercises
her royal property fright it's not a
full-time job although sometimes it
feels like a full-time job every year
mr. barber runs a census of the Swans
for Her Majesty a bit like an annual
checkup this is called Swan Appy and he
does it with a whole crew like this guy
this guy and this guy sworn up in has
taken place since the 12th century where
swans in those days were actually a very
very important food of course today
swans are our protected species and no
longer eaten we travel in six
traditional Rowan's gifts from some
Breann thames all the way up to Abington
and it's about a seventy nine mile
journey what do we say when we say s1
all up all what up each family of swans
would come across we will circle the
skiffs around them we will tie the wings
in their legs we will take them ashore
we will weigh them measure them and
check them for any injuries after we've
done that we will put a ring on them and
we will release them back into the river
see if these are the Queen swans ways
her majesty for all of this she did come
sworn up in a few years ago and
hopefully she enjoyed it she seemed to
enjoy it but I can't answer for the
Queen anyway I love swans a royal bird
people here in the United Kingdom they
love them and you know I want to make
sure that they survive for the future
all right gents let's toast great
nothing says Britain more than nope nope
keep going ah yes there it is a nice cup
of tea
[Music]
we know we have China to thank for
introducing tea to the Western world but
how did it make its way to England and
become the cultural obsession is today
well that's all thanks to one Portuguese
woman the year 1662
the person Catherine of Braganza she
just won the hand of England's King
Charles the second with the help of a
very large dowry including money
treasures and spices this worthwhile
trade made her the Queen of England
Scotland and Ireland when she arrived to
her new homeland she brought with her
packets of loose leaf tea in crates
labeled
transport de Vos aromatic us it's a
theory that this was later Berube ated
tu te a T now T could all be found in
England but was only really used for
medicinal purposes Catherine continued
drinking tea to her heart's content and
as the new royal everything about her
including her beverage habits was copied
by other ladies desperate to be just
like their Idol another thing Catherine
brought to the table from Portugal was
the idea of tea drinking experience she
popularized the use of porcelain tea
cups and mugs but the end of the 17th
century much of British aristocracy were
enjoying the hot beverage and soon
enough so was everyone else today while
tea can be found pretty much everywhere
it remains a special daily pastime four
Brits hmm so carry on and drink tea
people of England
[Music]
I think people say I look a bit like a
queen
in this outfit
and people call me your majesty people
come up and they curtsy it's almost like
living two lives really let's commence
[Music]
I'm Ella slack and I'm the queen
standing I've done it for over 30 years
now anything that the Queen does is
rehearsed if it's just going to a town
hall or opening a hospital I've probably
been a standing queen definitely more
than fifty times a standing is not a
look a lie I don't look like the Queen
but I'm the same sort of stature and
height I'm about virtually five-foot the
Queen's about five foot two but I live
at royal court on Queens promenade in
Royal Ramsey in the Isle of Man and the
Queen lives in Buckingham Palace in
London I drive a Ford gear automatic car
the Queen has been seen to drive Range
Rovers and most of the time she's in a
trophy driven car or in a carriage well
it started because I was at the BBC and
the producer who was doing the Cenotaph
came to see me and said that the Queen
had sent a message to say when she stood
at the Cenotaph this son was in her eyes
and so could we do anything about it
well I said to him would you like me to
come and stand in the position for you
because all the stage managers were six
footmen and then that led on to other
things I went in her royal carriage and
rode on the boat up to the Tower of
London and then there will be the State
Opening of Parliament
I've never been allowed to sit on on the
throne and the House of Lords I have to
lurk above it it's a very strict rule if
I'm in a carriage or a car I will wave
you know
it's like that
the events that I've been helping with
events that are transmitted worldwide in
millions of people again to watch
I look afterwards and watch the programs
going out and I'll see her there and
think I did it for you let's say you're
in London you need to get from the
London Eye to Buckingham Palace taxi
please
we would leave one hour right Belvedere
Road left Chitti Street oh wait you know
the whole group already what we have -
all London black cab drivers have to
have completed the knowledge that we
need to know all the streets and roads
in London to provide that service okay
let's go see with the Queen lives
[Music]
London is famous for its black taxis you
need to get to somewhere no sweat
because every black cabbie has to pass
insanely hard test known as the
knowledge like this guy hello my name is
Peter Allen I've been in London taxi
driver for nine years
okay all the knowledge is the test that
you have to pass in order to become a
London taxi driver it's the toughest
taxi test in the world the first thing
you have to do is learn what's called
the Blue Book as of cab drivers your
Bible you have to learn 320 routes
around London so that's six hundred and
forty quarter of a mile areas you have
to learn 25,000 streets and roads within
a six-mile radius or two Fabri Square in
London you have to learn every single
point of interest place of interest
apartment building housing estate lease
station mosques synagogues a few moments
later Woburn I want to show a club our
restaurant everything anyway aware of
pain passion you might want to go okay
then let's go to the exam center my name
is Katie channels and I'm the knowledge
of London manager so the exams are
several phases of oral appearances it's
basically an interview type situation
where you describe the streets and roads
attempting to use the shortest distance
between point A and point B at the
beginning we might ask them the name of
a theater where that theater is and by
the end of the knowledge we expect them
to know boys actually showing at that
theater
what on average it takes two to four
years to learn the knowledge the best
way to study is to go out onto the
streets on a scooter
isn't that right at us my name is a bass
actor you'd be studied knowledge for
about four and a half years now and my
next appearance is in about three weeks
time it's like a full-time job you wake
up in the morning go out on your by a
couple of hours come to the College
study study study here so it wasn't
sleeping over studying as well yeah
one in five who attempt the knowledge
actually pass that's the same success
rate as a u.s. Navy SEAL GPS and Sat
Navs are banned in the exam but why not
use them on the streets my GPS is here
and if we get somewhere and we see a
roads closed we need to say right that's
closed but I know if I go left here that
we
take me there I'll go right here that
would take me there we need to be able
to do all that as well as having a
conversation with the person in the back
and solving the world problems at the
same time Leicester Square to Big Ben
please so you'd leave Leicester Square
by Irving straight to turn into Charing
Cross
[Music]
fancy going shopping no no no no
whistling in the Burlington Arcade who
you we are the Burlington Beatles
probably the oldest and smallest police
force in the world you could say that we
police your manners
right okay well Mart Lord had beetle of
the bones in arcade tell us your story
the beetle story start before we get
into that what actually is a beetle to
be honest with you I think anybody
really knows we predates any police
force in the country right back to the
story go ahead mark the beetle story
started at this arcade okay and they
games you know so it's just like a
shopping center right yes okay third
time lucky
go ahead mark the beetle story started
on the 28th of March 18 19
London was very different people didn't
really trust the water so they drank
even gin or beer and obviously at least
was so startled behavior
people's role really was to keep all the
within the arcade and in fact that
tradition has carried on right away for
today our uniforms are made up of
several different layers we first of all
put on our waste gates then our frog
pose announcer our pants from the summer
or the autumn in the winter you will
still put on your waistcoat
you will then put on your cape and
you're sort of half the original rule
was here were no whistling because the
pickpockets would whistle signals to one
another no drunkenness play a musical
instrument you're not supposed to hurry
assumptions unlike an unladylike carry
your own parcels do you mustn't ring a
bicycle and the company ladies by the
way weren't also allowed it a lot of
those rules we couldn't enforce today we
still try to enforce it in their horrid
in we still try to enforce the low
wisdom it's all about behavior as long
as you're respecting those around you
and respecting the arcade
you'll be left alone and I put this
uniform on I represent nearly 200 years
worth of history
it makes me immensely proud yeah once
there's no attire if I'm one of you
that's actually true by the way isn't
just the you know the spill
[Music]
so these are jellied eels ills in jelly
German Jews and these ills with no jelly
like loads of eels drawers of ills hold
on to your seats this might get a bit
weird so we got this giant jiggly bowl
of jellied eels from this guy when I
miss John Chile's I work for Michiel
supply in Billy's gate fish market
we supply live eels to the catering
trade public I've been selling eels for
33 years since I love school focusing
lovely user base all farmed in Holland
they like the Rolls Royce of the
televisions there are very very slippery
by some their customers back in the 18th
century London's River Thames was
crawling with these eels
nowadays John is one of the last few ill
suppliers in London so John why were
there so popular yeah you need to speak
to one of the older fish mongers for
that oh okay then I'm 72 years old and I
eels everyday
perfect so Frank of Bradley's fish
supply what made them so popular back
then so those days it was it was
no-brainer everybody at jellied eels it
was an easy source to get and very
simple you put a hook out and they catch
herself eels are really edible and they
were full of goodness the people didn't
realize it then but they were they were
don't worry - the real good product and
we didn't have Indian Chinese takeaway
kebabs everything else so it was a it
was a source of food so how do you make
them quite easy to prepare you to head
off guts out chopped in pieces then we
cooked them the process of cooking is
more of an art you need them to be very
soft if you go past being soft all
you've got is mash thanks Frank
so pie shop owner cane what do they go
well with jellied eels and students are
very traditional with primary liquor in
the East End the London so you know it's
not for everybody
the world is changing a little bit
you do either like and will hate them
probably in the old days we will go
through maybe 50 or 60 bowls of ills a
week probably now we might do 10 or 12
so if you think about food around the
world you think about Paris and their
baguettes New York do you think about
the pizzas the New York cheesecakes
that's what they're synonymous for
London the traditional food in London is
polish annals that is a staple dial and
the taste
it's like eating basically a chunky
white fish
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you